against the agreement
all people should be removed prior to
that date they have got everything
after that we do not allow them
it will not be allowed in our country we
will take a different
stance
and let's speak to our political
correspondent joe pike who's following
events in westminster and joe hearing
from the taliban and hearing from the
defense secretary ben wallace this
morning it seems very unlikely this
deadline is going to move but the g7
leaders will be looking further ahead
during this meeting as well
they certainly will i think they want a
uh a common coordinated approach
something that we certainly didn't see
in the early stages of this crisis
remember boris johnson struggled to get
even a call with the president of the
u.s and he didn't seem to have spoken
too many of his opposite numbers that
hopefully should change and because
we're talking about seven very wealthy
nations it's certainly possible they'll
be discussed discussing uh other levers
that could be pulled to ensure that the
taliban's version of government uh works
well for them so we potentially talking
about economic
sanctions to ensure
that they do continue to work in a
positive way with the uk us and other
western nations certainly ben wallace as
you say seems to be playing down
expectation today about an extension and
we still do not know a lot of the key
numbers yeah we know that currently
about 2 000 people a day are being
removed from kabul airport by the uk uh
military that sort of pace could
continue or it could get a little bit
quicker but we don't know quite how many
people are on each country's list of
people that should be removed from the
country and of course mr wallace himself
has said that there will be some people
left behind so if there was to be an
accenture we don't necessarily know
quite how long
the uk us and other nations would want
it to be we're talking i think though
about days rather than anything longer
ultimately it is up to joe biden because
the u.s run and control kabul airport
and also up to the taliban of course
you've touched on their interview with
sky news saying there'll be consequences
if that deadline is not met and today
implying that they don't want uh people
to come to the airport you want afghans
to come to the airport to leave the
country specifically i think if those
are highly skilled afghans they same see
more concerned about engineers and
doctors
leaving the country people that they
would argue i suppose they need to
rebuild after 20 years of what they seem
to turn
occupation now that meeting boris
johnson's chairing should last uh one
hour 30 minutes for about a third of the
way through it and sarah jane we are
expecting to hear both from boris
johnson and joe biden after that's the
point i think we'll have a better idea
whether there has been an extension to
that 31st august deadline or any other
agreements about how to handle the
taliban in the future